resorts world coming together on the las
vegas strip is going to be here before
we know it
the property lights have been glowing
but it's the project itself
that really hopefully will bring some
boost to our local economy
christian casadas joining us now live
near resorts world he just finished the
four o'clock news 20 minutes ago
ran across your resorts world to give us
a glimpse of the operations do we know
exactly when the property might be
complete christian well denise i can
tell you that they haven't really nailed
down a specific date for
opening the property they just tell us
that it could be in the near future
possibly in the summer but first let me
direct your attention here
to the property behind me you can see so
much of the construction equipment
all around it but because as we know
well it's been in the works for several
years along the strip and it's promising
to boost the local economy
when it's complete now resorts world
president tells eight news now that the
property will be the largest
for its parent company genting here in
the u.s it will have an asian flair
mixed with an
urban design which hopes to attract all
types of customers
the 4.3 billion dollar hotel will
combine three hilton brands
into a 3 500 room resort tower and about
117
000 square feet of gaming they promise
new dining options luxury shopping
a state-of-the-art theater and of course
a nightlife they also have plans for
an infinity pool with a spectacular view
of the strip
another new feature will be its direct
access to the convention center
underground a project that the county
approved yesterday
our customers will go down to our
basement jump on the uh
the boring cars and they'll be at the
commissioner within 30 seconds
so that's that's already a done deal and
the clark county is now working on their
improvements
on the strip so we're building new
sidewalks new medias and things like
that
and hopefully there will be a bridge
down the road
well this property is hoping to boost
the local economy by hiring thousands of
workers to operate the facility
the focus they say is to get people back
on their feet fast
that process has already started by the
construction team currently working on
the site which is just south of sahara
near the convention center drive now
back out here live
i can tell you that another big feature
is the 100 000
square foot led screen on the west tower
there you see it on your screen
one of the largest in the country a
smaller screen on the east side
and of course a 50 foot diameter led
globe
for content now coming up at six o'clock
i will talk a little bit more about how
you can land a job
at resorts world christian casa is eight
news now